[Music]  what's that book you've been reading  about  [Music]  it's about heroes who get to go on  adventures  defeat the monsters the day  little boy from the south side of  chicago the only tourists get to do that  [Music]  this door it's about my father and the  secret birthright that's been kept from  us  you're going after it near the car  this is family business my family stay  together  [Music]  i go wrong with you boy i told you to  stay away from that damn place  there's something here that's trying to  get out  [Music]  everything was where and as it should be  from god to man  to creature  we're surrounded by monsters  i'm doing this to protect us you can't  win this game  [Music]  this legacy belongs to our family we  gotta face this new world  [Music]  instinct i'm claiming it  this is our family story  [Music]  you